[Musik]
also wenn man es positiv formulieren
will dann könnten die nächsten jahre
tatsächlich das bringen was sich die
koalition verspricht nämlich einen
aufbruch in europa dass man den
zusammenhang zusammenarbeit mit
frankreich irgend etwas schafft man sagt
das war damals ja dass die dritte große
koalition mit frankreich da irgendwas
hingelegt hat und dann gibt es viele
kleinigkeiten wo ich sagen würde das ist
durchaus sinnvoll ja also
breitbandausbau förderung des ländlichen
raums förderung von von öffentlichem
nahverkehr et cetera pp
also da ergeben sich schon viele
facetten die die sinnvoll sind
zuerst so erschreckend finde es wenn das
anders wäre wenn man es wenn man das
glas aber halb leer machen möchte dann
würde ich sagen die regierung profitiert
weiter davon dass ist der wirtschaft
sehr gut geht dass die steuereinnahmen
sprudeln dass man viel geld ausgeben
kann
aber im grunde genommen
diese koalition so zu sagen dass das das
abschluss kapitel der der ära merkel ist
also dass wir vieles weitermacht
vollendet repariert ja was sie innerhalb
ihrer zeit angestoßen hat aber das große
neue akzente gesetzt werden halte ich
eher für unwahrscheinlich
wir haben intensive ernsthafte sehr
tiefgehende sondierungen durchgeführt
das was jetzt in dem sanierungspaket
rund steht mit dem kann die union sehr
gut leben ich glaube dass da hat sie
sehr viel durchsetzen können
oder sagen wir mal viel verhindern
können was ihr vielleicht nicht so gut
geschmeckt hätte bis hin zur zur
obergrenze die da drin steht und das
halte ich für die große überraschung
dass das man sich da auch gar nicht
die spd wird sich schwertun
sie hat zwar jetzt gleich sofort mit dem
sondierungs papier auch gleich eine
liste von punkten veröffentlicht wo sie
behauptet hätte sich durchgesetzt
ich habe da nicht alles finden können
indem sie das papier also zum beispiel
kooperationsverbot dass das aufgehoben
werden soll kann ich nicht sehen dass
die obergrenze verhindert werden sollte
kann ich auch nicht sehen dass das in
der gesundheits in der
gesundheitspolitik konnte man ziele
nicht durchsetzen es gibt keinen nicht
auch den geringsten einstieg in eine
bürgerversicherung die man sich hätte
vorstellen können
ich glaube dass wir hervorragende
ergebnisse erzielt haben
für uns ist das was wir in diesen
sanierungsvertrag geschrieben haben
keine rhetorik wir meinen das ernst und
ich glaube das kann ich haben wir in
unserer langen verhandlungen sagen dass
man auch die beiden anderen teilen sehr
ernst wie arbeit sozialdemokratische
partei einstimmig in der
sondierungsrunde entschieden unseren
gremien die heute hier im hause tagen
vorzuschlagen
einen beschluss zu fassen dem parteitag
der spd zu empfehlen der parteiführungen
man dazu geben koalitionsverhandlungen
zur bildung einer bundesregierung
aufzunehmen ich glaube dass es für die
partei schwierig sein wird zumindest mal
die funktionäre wie die mitglieder
darauf reagieren weiß ich nicht aber es
wird schon schwierig sein die davon zu
überzeugen dass das ein großer wurf ist
für das buch